[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
بعد محادثات مع ماكرون في باريس مستشار
المانيا يؤكد مواصله تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا
وسائل الاعلام الكويتيه تقول ان الحكومه
تنوي التقدم غدا باستقالتها للقياده
السياسيه
الجمارك السعوديه تطلق مبادره لانهاء فتح
البضائع خلال الساعتين بكافه المنافذ
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
بلومبرج تكشف عن استمرار اهتمام الصندوق
الاستثمارات السعوديه
بالاستحواذ على امتياز سباقات فورمولا 1
كريستيانو رونالدو يلعب اليوم اولى
مبارياتهم مع النصر السعودي في مواجهه
الاتفاق على ملعب مرسول طارق
حياكم الله اعلن قصر الاليزي عن اجراء
الرئيس الفرنسيه
الالماني بعد تاجيل الاجتماع لاكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر ويهدف الاجتماع لتعميق التعاون
في مجالات الامن والصناعه والطاقه وفقه
بيان الناس تاره الذي اوضح ايضا ان مجلس
الوزراء المشترك يعمل على تقريب المواقف
الفرنسيه والالمانيه على الساحتين
الاوروبيه والدوليه وبالاخص اجراءات دعم
اخرى
عربه مستشار اداره الرئاسيه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل ابو دلياك عن شعوره بخيبه الامل
بشان تسليحه اوكرانيا رغم تفاهمه للموانع
التي تواجهها الدول الا ان ذلك التباطؤ
يزيد من قتل الجنود والمدنيين الاوكرانيين
على حد قوله بودنيا شدد ايضا على اهميه
الدور الالماني القيادي في الوضع الراهب
موضحا ان 300 الى 400 من دبابات ليوبارد
الالمانيه كفيله بالتفوق على ما يصل الى
ثلاثه الاف دبابه من الحقبه السوفياتيه
فضلا عن مساهمتها في تسريع وتيره الحرب
وتبدا المرحله النهائيه وفق مستشار
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه والذي اوضح كذلك انك
بحاجه للدبابات والصواريخ طويله المدى
مشيرا او كما توقع ان تزيد روسيا من
قواتها ومعداتها سوفيتيه القديمه
انتقد رئيس الوزراء البولنديه قرر المانيا
عتم تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات اليو بارد
ووصف الموقفه بانه غير مقبول وقال رئيس
وزراء بولندا انه اذا رفضت برلين امداد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات فسيتم تشكيل تحالف
صغير من الدول المستعده للتبرع ببعض
معداتها الحديثه بينها الدبابات مشيرا الى
ان القنابل الروسيه لا تزال تستهدف اهداف
المدنيه وتقتل الاوكرانيين بينهم النساء
والاطفال
اكد رئيس السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيه بوريلا ان عدم اتخاذ ان
عدم اتخاذ قرار سياسي لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات يتعلق الى حد كبير بالموقف
الالماني مشيرا الى انه يفضل تزويد كيف
بالدبابات في ظل الوضع الحالي للحرب واضاف
بريل لانه يجب قبول المخاطر المحتمله
لتزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه اللازمه خاصه
وان هناك دول اوروبيه لم ترغب في تسليم
مقاتلات وطائرات حربيه الى اوكرانيا بسبب
تلك المخاطر واقال بوريل ان المساعدات
التي قدمها الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اوكرانيا
وصلت الى نحو 50 مليار يورو الى جانب
مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات ونصف
المليار يورو من الصندوق الاوروبي واكثر
من سبعه مليارات ونصف المليار يورو
مساهمات دوليه
نعود مره اخرى الى باريس
وفي ظل هذه متابعه طبعا لهذه الزياره
زياره المستشاره الالماني الى
الاليزيه ومعنى من هناك مراسل العربيه
حسين قنيبر حسين مساء الخير مرحبا بكم معي
في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض اولا ما هي
الملفات التي سيتم نقاشها بين الزعيمين
هذا اليوم في اجتماعهما
اهلا بك نايف نعمه وصل قبل دقائق من الان
الى هنا الى قصر الى حيث انا موجود مستشار
الالمانيه
في الشقه الثاني من اللقاءات الفرنسيه
الالمانيه التي كانت بدات صباحا بالشق
الاحتفال الاحتفال بذكرى مرور 60 عاما على
توقيع معاهده التعاون بين البلدين الشق
الاحتفالي كان في جامعه السوربون حيث حضر
المستشار الالماني والرئيس الفرنسي كما
حضرت رئيسته برلمانيين في البلدين وحضر
300 برلماني فرنسي والماني كما حضر 18
وزيرا المانيا و19 وزيرا
كل ذلك للاحتفال بذكر الستين لتوقيع
معاهده التعاون بين المانيا وفرنسا اما
بالنسبه لموضوعات النقاش هي تتمحور كما
قال مصدر رئ فرنسي نايف حول ثلاثه محاور
رئيسيه المحور الاول مواجهه التحديات
البيئيه والصناعيه والاقتصاديه وخصوصا
التحديات المتعلقه بموضوع الطاقه وهذا كان
محور خلافات بين الجانبين مؤخرا والمحور
الثاني مواجهه التحديات الدفاعيه والامنيه
وهذا المحور بدوره كان ايضا موضع خلاف بين
البلدين والمحور الثالث هو مناقشه مستقبل
اوروبا هذا الاجتماع ياتي في ظل همم
خلافات بين البلدين حسين يعني نحن نريد
العوده فقط
والتذكير بابرز يعني اسباب هذه الخلافات
بين البلدين واللاتي التزمت معهم هذا
اللقاء وربما كانت هي همم يعني همم السمه
التي سبقت هذه الزياره
نعم مجلس الوزراء المشترك الذي سينعقد بعد
قليل سيكون الاول منذ عده اشهر بعد ان
الغي مجلس وزراء مشترك سابق كان مقررا في
شهر اكتوبر في السادس والعشرين منه وسعيد
عنه بلقاء بين الرئيس والمستشار وحدهما
اسباب الخلافات كثيره اولا الخلاف حول
التعاطي مع موضوع الطاقه بعد وقف روسيا
تزويد الاوروبيين بالغاز الروسي حينها
اعلن المستشاره الالماني تخصيص مبلغ 200
مليار يورو لتمكين المواطنين الالمان من
مواجهه تداعيات ارتفاع اسعار الغاز يومها
اعتبرت فرنسا ان القرار الالماني جاء من
خارج نطاق خطه اوروبيه شامله ويغلب
المصالح الوطنيه الالمانيه على المصالح
الاوروبيه والخلاف الثاني كان حول الدفاع
على المستشار الالماني تخصيص مبلغ 100
مليار يورو لجعل الجيش المانيا الافضل
تجهيزا في اوروبا اعتبرت فرنسا ذلك خروجا
على سياسه ماكرون ودعواته المتلاح خليه اا
تامين استقلال استراتيجي لاوروبا خصوصا من
الناحيه العسكريه والخلاف الثالث كان حول
الصناعات العسكريه حيث اتجهت المانيا الى
التعاون في مجال الصناعه العسكريه مع
الولايات المتحده ودول في الحلف الاطلسي
وحتى مع اسرائيل التي تنافس ايطاليا
وفرنسا في مجال الصناعه العسكريه كان تمت
اتجاها المانيا الى احتمال التزوج بصواريخ
اسرائيليه من طراز ارو ثلاثه كل ذلك ادى
الى توفير العلاقات بين البلدين وهذا ما
سيناقشه الجانبان في يوم طويل من اللقاءات
بدا في جامعه السوربون احتفاليه ثم هنا في
قصر قبل قليل ناحيه مناقشه الموضوعات
الخلافيه وسبل تعزيز التعاون بين البلدين
وعند الساعه الخامسه مساءا بالتوقيت
المحلي سيعقد الجانبان المستشار الالماني
والرئيس الفرنسي مؤتمر الصحافيا يسبق غدا
عمل يسبقه عفوا غداء عمل بين الوفدين
الالماني والفرنسي ثم ينتهي النهار في
غداء خاص لا يحضره المستشار الالماني
والرئيس الفرنسي نايف اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من من قصر الاليزيا في باريس
مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر
متابعه لذات الموضوع من باريس ينضم الينا
الدكتور محمد سيف الدين الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض يعني موضوع
الدبابات كليو بارد الالمانيه كان الموضوع
ربما الاسخن خلال همم ساعه القليله
الماضيه الموقف الالماني برايك لاي مدى
سيصمود في همم يعني او منعته من ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا حتى الان هل سيظل
مرتبطا بارسال واشنطن دباباتها الى همم
كيف وبعد ذلك ربما قد تتخذ برلين هذه
الخطوه واشنطن
يعني يبدا بدايه ان برلين وباريس بدات
تدركان بان التهور او التسرع في يعني في
تقديم كل ما يمكنهما تقديمه لاوكرانيا قد
يعود بنتائج كارثيه خصوصا بموازاه تصريحات
الروسيه التي تؤشر على ذلك والتي تشير الى
الاحتمالات الكارثيه في مملكه لو تم تجهيز
اوكرانيا بمعدات تقلب التوازن او يعني
تحدث ااا تحولات على الارض واخرها تصريحات
يعني نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
الرئيس السابق وهو تحدث اليوم وفي كلامه
اشارات خطيره جدا عن احتمالات توسع هذا
النزاع وخصوصا نحو الدول الاوروبيه
المانيا تتمسك بان يسير التحالف الغربي
سواسيه وفي لحظه نفسها والتزامن لمساعده
اوكرانيه وهي وباريس تبدو وهان من خلال
تحليل المواقفه ما خصوصا في الاسابيع
الاخيره بانهما تريدان الحفاظ على خط عوده
للعلاقات مع روسيا فيما لو تمت تم التواصل
الى حلول سياسيه في امات ابعد من ذلك لذلك
مع مع العلم بان المانيا ابدت رغبتها يعني
هذا خبر جديد بارسال 19 دبابه همم طراز
ليبرت اثنين لكنها من خط انتاج قديم من
خطين انتاج قديمين بالاحرف همم دبابات
تستخدم للتدريب ولل المحاكاه لظروف
المعركه وليست وليست الدبابات الجديده
التي تستطيع ان تؤثر والتصريحات
الاوكرانيه اليوم تشير الى الحاجه الى بين
نوع من الدبابات الى اوكرانيا
الالمانيه هذا اليوم الا يعني ذلك بانها
خطوه استقباقيه من برلين
للموافقه لتسليم هذه الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا
لماذا قد تقوم بتسليم هذا النوع من
الدبابات حتى وان كان قديم يعني ما نستطيع
نعم
ما نستطيع ان نثق به حتى هذه اللحظه بانه
خطوه لها علاقه بحمايه الموقف الالماني
وتمثيل هذا الموقف في مقابل الحلفاء
الاخرين وبالتالي في المانيا تريد ان تقول
يعني من خلال تحليل هذا الموقف بان على
الحلفاء الاخرين ان يقدموا ما لديهم وعلى
الولايات المتحده ان تقدم الدبابات عبر
رمز التي يعني توازي ليقعد اثنان في
المواصفات وعدم التحجج ب- يعني حاجتها
للصيانه بمصاريفها العاليه من الطاقه
والحاجه للتزاوج بالوقود كل 250
ارسال التالي
الى الى اوكرانيا
هذا هذا ما عبروا عنه بصراحه في في يعني
في اجتماع رمشتاين الذي عقد في القاعده
العسكريه بالمانيا قبل ايام وقال الالمان
في ذلك الوقت تحت ضغوط الدول الاخرى مثل
البولندا التي تطالب بالارسال الفوري
للدبابات بانهم ملتزمون يعني بالتعاون
عندما تقدم الدول الاخرى على ارسال هذه
الدبابات لا ننسى ان الولايات المتحده
لديها يعني قدرات مماثله من الدبابات
وبريطاني ايضا لديها قدرات ودبابات خاصه
بها ايضا يعني توازي هذه المواصفات
الالمانيه وبالتالي لماذا يطلب من المانيا
ترسل القدر الاكبر من من الدبابات خصوصا
ان يعني في باريس وفي وفي برلين الان يعود
الحديث وخصوصا مع اجتماع اليوم عن الجيش
الاوروبي وفكره الجيش الاوروبي ولهذا
معاني كثيره بالمحصله يعني هناك ضغط
امريكي شديد جدا
لارسال هذه المساعدات لوقف التقدم الروسي
الذي يبدو يعني انه وجد لاستعاده مناطق
عديده في في محيط يعني همم موت الان وفي
همم زبروجين يبدو ان هناك تقدم للجيش
الروسي يريد الامريكيون ايقافه باي ثمن
بهذه اللحظه واستخدام القدرات الاوروبيه
في ذلك بينما يخاف الاوروبيون من تداعيات
ذلك خصوصا بموازاه التصريحات الشديده
اللهجه من من روسيا والتي تبدو جديه
بالمناسبه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي
في نشره الرابعه من تاريخ الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
افادت وسائل الاعلام من كويتيه يعني نيه
الحكومه تقديم الثقالتها الى قياده
السياسيه يوم غدا ياتي ذلك بينما تتمسك
الحكومه الكويتيه بموقفها تجاه الازمه
السياسيه الاخيره واعرفها تقديم اي تعهدات
لانه والكويتيين فيما يتعلقوا بالقوانين
الشعبيه
من الكويت ينضم لنا المحامي والباحث عبد
الكريم المجهول سيد عبد الكريم مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
من الذي قد يدفع الحكومه الكويتيه الى
تقديم استقالتها وصحه هذه الانباء
الكويت
هذا الخبر فهذا الخبر او جزء من سلسله
معارك تكسير العظم بين الحكومه والبرلمان
منذ 60 عام اصبح الاصل عندنا في الممارسه
الديمقراطيه هو الصدام والتهدئه والتوافق
على استثنائيه لا تدوم بسبب مفاهيم
ومعايير للممارسه تم غرسها منذ تاسيس
البرلمان قبل 60 عاما 61 عام وانا لازم ان
يكون ما يصير النائب معارض سلاحي الا ان
ياتي في اخر الصيام ودائما يصعد وان
التوافق والخطاب العقلاني هذا يمثل حاله
قد تخزيه امام ناخذين وقد لا تعيدها اهل
المجلس فالمشكله ليست يعني في استقاله
الحكومه لان احنا حاله الصيام وحاله
التوتر اصبحت حاله عندنا الاصل هي
الممارسه الطبيعيه عندنا هي حاله اصطدام
والتوتر واصبحت التهدئه والخطاب العقلاني
ليدفع العمليه السياسيه الى النمو
والازدهار اصبح حال استثنائيه لا تدوم
بسبب مفاهيم تعيسه تم غرسها في المشهد
السياسي فهذه استقاله الحكومه اصبح خبر
يعني مستشار وطبيعي في حاله الممارسات
الديمقراطيه عندنا في الكويت ومشهد
السياسي
في الكويت وربما خلال الاسبوع الماضي مع
المكرمه الاميريه والعفو ايضا كذلك عند
بعض
المحكومين كانت خطوه يعني لترطيب ربما
الاجواد تمهيد همم ايضا ال- ال- يعني
تمهيد ما يمكن تمهيده في همم الخلافات بين
بعض النواب المعارضين وكذلك ايضا مع
الحكومه همم الكويتيه
هل فشلت هذه الخطوه برايك
اثناء الحمله الانتخابيه وبعد ان يصل
البرلمان يقدم هذه كتسجيل موقف وليس حرصا
على تحقيق القانون هناك قوانين تتطلب
موازمات معينه سياق ظرف يعني تاريخي معين
حتى تمرر انت اذا تمردها بطريقه فجه
وبصدام مبكر فانت اني ما تمردها يعني
تحقيقها نفع المواطنين بها بقدر حتى تسجل
الموقف لما تعاد مره اخرى في انتخابات
اخرى الى جماهير تقول انا سجلت موقف في
ذلك اليوم وهذه مشكله يعني يعاني منها
كثير من يقدمونه انفسهم معارضه صاحيين
عندنا العفو ولا من جاء كان يعني المتتبع
يعني نحنا نسمي الاشياء مسمياتها المتتبع
سياحه من التاريخ يجد جزء من المعفو عنهم
كانوا جزء في يعني حاله الاحتقان ودفع
المشهد السياسي للاحتقان فتقدم بعض النواب
ببعض القوانين كوارث الضغط على الحكومه
بعد ما تم العفو تورط هؤلاء انه في تقديم
هذا
وضعه شروط مسبقه على الحكومه والحكومه
وقوه هذه الشروط المسبقه ولذلك عندنا الى
المربع الاول المربع الصيام اللي ما راح
ينتهي اذا لم تغير الارضيه ولم تغير
المفاهيم اللي تمشها في مشهد السياسي
وبالتالي ما هي الخطوه التي ستعقب استقاله
هذه الحكومه الحكومه همم الكويتيه الحكومه
الجديده يعني حتى اصلنا لم ااه لم يمر على
هذه الحكومه اقل من من اشهر حتى الان
استقاله الحكومه وتشكيل الحكومه جديده او
حل البرلمان والرجوع للشارع مره اخرى
والدخول في دوامه جديده من انتخابات
وتشكيل الحكومه وسياق تاريخي متكرر لم
ينتهي منذ 60 عام فيعني السيناريو مستقبلا
ومعروف من خلال الماضي وبالتالي سيناري
وحل مجلس الامه ربما قد يكون سيناريو
محتمل بشكل كبير في تقديرك
نعم قد يكون هناك ابطال من المحكمه
الدستوريه يعني حتى في اخبار تسربت من
الحكومه يعني الحضور الى ان يتم الانتهاء
من الاحكام محك
مه الدينيه قد يكون في المحكمه الدستوريه
قد يكون في حل من القياده السياسيه وقد
يتم تشكيل الحكومه اخرى بس انه رياضات
المتكرره يعني عبر التاريخ البرلماني
الكويتي فما فيه جديد يعني على يعني سطح
نفس السياقات تتكرر ولكن يختلف بعض الشخوص
وبرفع وتيره المزايدات والمشاحنات اللي لا
تخلق اجواء سياسيه يتم من خلالها خلق تواف
استخدم البلد والمواطن وتعود على المواطن
بقوانين يرى اثاره
ا على هي من المواطنه المطحون اللي ينشغل
في الغلاء ويبحث عن حياه كريمه بدلا من
صراعات سياسيه تبحث عن نفوذه وتبحث عن
امجاد شخصيه
عبد الكريم المجهولي
في لقاء مع العربيه كشفت سميه المحمود
مديره الشؤون الاعلاميه في برنامج مسام
لنزع الالغامي في اليمن ان البرنامج
السعودي تمكن من نزع اكثر من 380,000 لاغ
من زراعه الحوثي بالاضافه للعبوات الناسفه
والذخائر غير المنفجره منذ انطلاقه في
يونيو 2018 حتى يناير الجاري يذكر ان
حلقات برنامج خذ العلم كامله عبر حساب
العربيه السعوديه في منصه تويتر
همم منذ بدايه المشروع في يونيو من عام
2018 حتى اليوم على ازاله ما يزيد على
382,000 لغم وعبوه ناسفه وذخيره غير
منفجره همم حيث همم تم تطهير ما يزيد على
43 مليون متر مربع من الاراضي في اليمن
كانت مفخخه بالالغام والدخار غير منفجره
حيث غطى نشاط المشروع همم منذ انطلاقه على
11 منطقه يعني حيث انه تشير تقارير حقوقيه
انا مليشيات الحوثي زرعت همم اكثر من
مليونير لغم او دت بحياه اكثر من 20,000
المدنيه
هاي لهذه الصور المباشره من بلجيكا هذه
الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه كمان شاهد الان على الشاشه وهي
وقفه ضمنيه
اغاثه
محتجز في ايران
[موسيقى]
طلاب وطالبات سعوديين يحققون 94 او 94
جائزه علميه دوليه في عام 2022
حياكم الله من جديد في اخبار الاستثمارات
ذكرت وكاله صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه
مليار دولار شامله الديون اضافت وكاله
كانه في حال غيرت شركه ليبرتي ميديا
الملكه للامتياز فورميلا وان قررها للبيع
فان الصندوق الثروه السعودي سيكون جادا
بالاستحوا عليه
عملت هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك
السعوديه عن بدء تطبيق مبادره الفسح خلال
ساعتين في جميع منافذها الجمركيه البريه
والبحريه والجويه بالتعاون مع 26 جهه
حكوميه حيث تهدي في المبادره الى تيسير
وزياده مرونه العمليات الجمركيه ورفع
مؤشرات الاداء والانتاجيه في جميع المنافذ
الجمركيه في البلاد
تمكين قطاع الاعمال والافراد من فتح
ارسالياتهم خلال ساعتين بحيث انه يصبح
المملكه
في مركز لوجستيه عالمي طبعا عملنا على عده
عوامل اساسيه اهمها رفع مستوى الالتزام
للمستوردين والمخلصين وكذلك تمكين محرك
المخاطر من تحديد مستوى الخطر للارساليات
بالاضافه الى التعاون مع الجهات الحكوميه
واللي يساعدنا بشكل مباشر في الوصول
المستهدفات
من المنطقه الجمركيه بمنفذ جسر الملك فهد
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي عبدالرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
خلينا نعرف اولا كيف تتم هذه الاليه كيف
يتم الفسح خلال ساعتين يعني هذه المبادره
اللي اعلنت عنها هيئه الزكاه والضريب
والجمارك السعوديه
عبد الرحمن تسمعني
طيب يبدو اااا انا لدينا مشكله تقنيه
نحاول تجاوز هذه المشكله التقنيه في الصوت
من المصدر ثم نعود الى زميل عبد الرحمن
العصيمي وفي الرابعه ايضا اعلنت مؤسسه
الملك عبد العزيز ورجاله للموهبه والابداع
موهبه عن فوز الطلاب السعوديين ب 94 جائزه
علميه دوليه في عام 2022 منها اثنتان
وسبعون ميداليه متمثله في المسابقات
والاولمبياد الدوليه والاقليميه وتنتان
وعشرون جائزه عالميه في مشاركه الفريق
السعودي بمعرض ايسف 2002 و2020
[موسيقى]
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
كريستيانو رونالدو يلعب اليوم اولى
مبارياتهم مع النصر السعودي في مواجهه
الاتفاق على ملعب مرسول طارق
حياكم الله من جديد نعود مره اخرى الى
المنطقه الجمركيه بمنفذ جسر الملك فهد
وينضم الينا من هناك مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
تسمعني اولا
اسمعك نايف عبد الرحمن الفسيخ خلال ساعتين
كيف يتم الاليه همم كيف يتم ايضا كذلك
تطبيقات
نعم نايف هذا الرقم وصلت اليه الجمارك
السعوديه بعد يعني جهود كبيره بدلتها
بالتعاون مع اكثر من جهه حكوميه في عام
2017 كان الفسح الجمركي يستغرق 12 يوما
ليصل الان في بدايه 20 23 الى ساعتين فقط
يعني رقم كبير جدا ومنجز مهم ضمن المستهد
رؤيه 20 30 فيما يتعلق
بتحقيق
الاستقرار الاقتصادي وتحفيز همم الشركات
للقدوم الى السعوديه ستدع زميل المصور
ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات نحن هنا من امام همم
منفذ المركبات المغادره في جسر الملك فهد
هذا المنفذ ايضا شاهي تطور كبير نايف يعني
تم تحديث الاجهزه المستخدمه والنظام
الالكتروني المستخدم بحيث يتم تخليص
السيارات المغادره من السعوديه الى مملكه
البحرين واي عبر منفذ بري اه اه في
السعوديه بتقريبا ثواني قليله جدا في ما
يتعلق بالفسح خلال ساعتين هيئه الزكاه
والضريبه والجمارك اكدت بان هذه المرحله
اتت بعد تعاون
وتنسيق متوسط طبعا بين الجهات الحكوميه
وهذا الاعلان ياتي بالتزامن نايف مع
احتفال الهيئه باليوم العالمي للجمارك هذا
العمل واتمام هذه المرحله همم يتم من
خلالها دعم مبادرات تيسير تجاره نايف همم
وايضا محاوله تقديم نموذج لتوحيد الجهود
بين جهات الفسحه الجمركيلي همم تعزيز
مكانه السعوديه كمركز لوجستي عالمي ايضا
هيئه الجمارك والضريبه والزكاه تسعى من
خلال هذه الخطوه الى تعزيز قطاع الخدمات
اللوجستيه وايضا دعم التنافسيه عالميا
بالنسبه للسعوديه ايضا محاوله التاكيد على
مكانه السعوديه ودورها في حركه الاقتصاد
العالمي الهيئه وبحسب تصريح اا رئيسها اكد
بان هذه المبادره اجراءات الفسح واستعداد
المبادرات والبرامج هدفها جوده ورفع
الجوده بالنسبه لاداء العمل الجمركي
بالاضافه طبعا الى محاوله انشاء جيل جديد
من الموظفين الذين لديهم امكانيات وقدرات
كبيره بالتعامل مع البضائع والشاحنات
القادمه وايضا همم بالنسبه للشركات
القادمه الى السعوديه جهود كبيره تبذلها
هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك وايضا من
المتوقع خلال الايام القليله المقبله ان
يكون هناك المزيد من المبادرات نايف
لتسهيل عمليه الجمارك ربما نشهد في العام
المقبل او الذي يليه
التخليص الفسحه الجمركي في ساعه او في
دقائق قليله طبعا بالتعاون مع اكثر من 25
جهه حكوميه وهيئه حكوميه همم تنسق مع هيئه
الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك عبد الرحمن على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل الصوره التي
نقلتها لنا مباشره من المنطقه الجمركيه
بالمنفذ جسر الملك فهد شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
الرحمن الحسيمي مراسل العربيه
ينطلقوا اليوم معرض الفضاء الذي تنظمه
الهيئه الملكيه لمدينه الرياض في مقر واحه
الملك سلمان للعلوم ويقدموا المعرض ل 30
يوما تجارب تعليميه تفاعليه حيه تمكنوا
الزوار بمختلفه فئاتهم العمريه من التعرف
على علوم الفضاء واكتشافه بشكل مباشر
من معرض الفضاء في واحه الملك سلمان
للعلوم بالرياض ينضم الى مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
ويبدو ايضا ان صوره عبد المحسن لم تصلح
حتى اللحظه وصل عبد المحسن بالسلامه حياك
الله يا عبد المحسن
خلينا نعرف عن هذا المعرض ما الذي يحتوي
متى بدا كم سيستمر كذلك
مرحبا بك ان تتحدث عن انقطاع الفضاء فهو
ملف جديد بدا يدخل الى السعوديه خلال ربما
السنوات القليله الماضيه بعد انطلاق رؤيه
2030 واطلاق عدد كبير من المبادرات
فبالتاليين نشاهد اليوم هذا المعرض الضخم
الذي يريد من خلاله همم القائمون عليه
وتحديدا اللي هي الملكيه لمدينه الرياض
على التعريف ليس فقط المهتمين والمختصين
في قطاع الفضاء ولكن كافه السكان
لمراحل تطور همم
مركبات الفضائيه او حتى الرحلات الفضائيه
وقطاع الفضاء بشكل عام همم دعني اضعكم
بالصوره حيث نتواجد في المرحله الثانيه من
همم المراحل الثمان وتحديدا هناك ثمانيه
مراحل وضعت لتجربه همم الزائر والمهتم هذه
الكبسوله نايف وضعت طبق الاصل اول رحله
فضاء همم
اطلقت ووصل بها البشر الى
الفضاء حيث عاده من هذه رواد الفضاء عبر
هذه الكبسوله بالاضافه الى استعراض عدد
كبير من المعدات ومن الملابس والمقتنيات
التي تم استخدامها في رحلات فضاء مختلفه
للي وكاله ناسا وايضا لعدد من رواد الفضاء
بالاضافه الى استعراض همم اكبر صاروخ في
هذا المكان وهو مجسم لاول صاروخ اطلق في
تاريخ البشريه في الحقيقه هنالك عدد من
الصور الملفته نايف في هذا المعرض حيث
المراحل الثمان التي تم وضعها تخوض او
تجعل الزائر يخوض مغامرات وايضا همم
التعليم بالترفيه وهي واحده من الاساليب
والادوات المهمه التي يتم استخدامها في
هذا المعرض كما تشاهد في هذه الصوره ايضا
هنالك مقتنيات يتم عرضها سواء كان من
الاكل الذي يتم استخدامه من قبل رواد
الفضاء ومعلب بطريقه
تحفظ هذا الماء في الفضاء ايضا استعراض
العلم الامريكي والصيني عفوا الاتحاد
السوفيتي
والامريكي وهي من الدول الاوائل الدول
التي وصلت الى تلك المنطقه تحديدا الفضاء
الامريكا وايضا القمر هي اول رحله عبر
الاتحاد السوفيتي اذا هذا المعرض يخوض همم
يغوص بزائره في عدد همم متعدد من المراحل
الثمان سواء كان عبر هذا التاريخ او من
المراحل الاستكشافيه الاخرى او حتى من
استطلاع تاريخ السعوديه في الفضاء واين
تريد ان تصل السعوديه في همم الفضاء
بالاضافه الى عدد من همم ادوات الاخرى
التي باستخدامها من عمليات الالعاب
التفاعليه التي يتم خلالها تعريف الناس
على هذا القطاع همم الذي ربما نايف سنسمع
عنها اخبار كثيره خلال الفتره القادمه في
السعوديه لاسيما وانه لم تمضي اكثر من
ثمانيه اشهر عن اطلاق او اربعه اشهر
تقريبا في هذا الحدود منذ اطلاق برنامج
رواد الفضاء الذي سيرسل اول رائده فضاء
سعوديه الى همم الى الفضاء همم في همم
غضون هذه السنافر بالتالي اهتمام كبير
بالفضاء همم تعريف الناس والمهتمين في هذا
العالم اشكرك عبد المحسن على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل التي زودتنا بها من
معرض الفضاء في واحه الملك سلمان للعلوم
بالرياض العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا
لك يا عبد المحسن
الرياض تحتضر الحدث الاكبر في مشهد الفني
باحياه حفل توزيعي جوائز الذي خطف الاضواء
بنجوم العالم التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اطلت العاصمه السعوديه الرياض متصدره
للمشهد الفني عالميا في حفل اسطوري جوائز
جو وورد 20 23
[موسيقى]
اكيد نحن العالم عربي واحد بدي قلك عبر
العربيه انه ااه نعم اوروبا الجديده هي في
الشرق الاوسط وعلى راسها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن عالم واحد نحن نمبر وان باذن
الله هنكون مثل ما ولي العهد لنا ان شاء
الله هذا فخر لنا شكرا على الاشياء هذه
جميله وهمم
قالها معي مستشار تركي ال الشيخ فوق
الخيال احنا قاعد نعيش فوق الخيال هذا
الاحتفاليه اللي انا دائما اقول اي
احتفاليه هذه تمت زراعه شجره لتصبح مظل
الفن لتصبح مركز الفن نقول للعالم انه
مركز الفني القادم من يوم ورايح هو
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الموسم الثالث من جو- وورد اضاف جائزه
جديده تحت اسم صناع الترفيه الماسيه تم
تقديمها لرئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم
اللي تشوفونه الان في الرياض هو البدايه
بدايه بسيطه جدا العمل مهما كان القياده
مكه واعطه واذا ما في رجال ينفذون على
الارض مثل الرجال هذا اللي قاعد قدامنا
فعالي مستشار تركي ال الشيخ
ومثله رجال اخرين اليوم موجودين عملوا عمل
المستحيل وجبار كما تم تكريم فنانين من
حول العالم بجوائز فخريه خاصه بصناعه
ترفيه وجوائز الانجاز مدى الحياه وشخصيه
العامه وكان للراحلين نصيب من الحضور في
الحفل روما
يعني في تنظيم المهرجانات امانه حضرتنا
الاول حضاره الثانيه والان هذا الثالث
يعني التوهج يزيد سنه عن سنه قاعد يزيد
التوهج بشكل فوق التخيل يعني
وخطف النجم اشرف حكيمي جائزه رياضي
المفضله وجائزه الرياضيه المفضله خطفتها
مريم صالح بالله
شكرا جزيلا انا سعيد بتواجد في هذا البلد
ليله خاصه نستمتع فيها انا وعائلتي شكرا
لدعمكم
في ما حصد مسلسل صالون زهره على جائزه
المسلسل المفضل صالون زهره صادق الصباح
قاعد يعني
يجنن المشاهدين ليش لا والله بالعكس عشان
اسلي المشاهدين
والحقيقه انه الواحد جرب ينوع بالاعمال
كما حصل على جائزتي الممثله المفضله
والممثل المفضل دميا الفنانه نادين نجيم
والفنان ابراهيم حجاج
ان شاء الله يا رب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله في في رمضان يارب
والله مجرد وصول النهائيات فيني باكيا
عندي احساس انك انت هتاخذي عندي احساس انك
انت هتاخذي الجاي
نجوم الفن والرياضه عالميا توافدوا
للعاصمه السعوديه للسير على السجاده
البنفسجيه في واحده من ابرز ليالي موسم
الرياضه
بتاريخ يمتدوا لاكثر من 300 سنه تستعرض
متاحف حي طريف التاريخي في الدرعيه الارثه
الثقفيين والاجتماعي والسياسي للدوله
السعوديه بمراحلها المختلفه مشاهده
المتاحف منذ افتتاحها قبل شهر ونصف اقبلا
كبيرا من الزوار والسياح نشاهد
بوصفها اكبر مشروع تراثي حول العالم تتوزع
المتاحف التراثيه في حي طريف التاريخي في
الدرعيه هذا الممر يذهب بك الى متحف
الدرعيه الذي يغوص بك الى تاريخ طويل 300
سنه يعود بك الى تاريخ الدوله السعوديه
الاولى والثانيه والثالثه وابرز محطاتها
ورجالاتها واذا المقتنيات
المتواجده همم من خلال هذه الحقبه من
السنوات التي يتم عرضها في هذا المكان
كثير من السوء الزوار الاف الزوار بداوا
يتوافدون الى هذا المتحف منذ شهر ونصف حيث
افتتح هذا المتحف همم
سوري
انا هنا منذ حوالي يوم واحد وانا اتجول
للتعرف على تاريخ البلاد انا قادم من
بريطانيا وافكارنا عن المنطقه العربيه
قليله هناك افكار نمطيه عن كل دوله لهذا
السبب الى هنا للتعرف على التاريخ الحقيقي
ساويوعك يمكن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى الان مدهشه
وقد احببتها كثيرا جئنا الى هنا للتعرف
على ثقافه البلاد وجذورها واصولها ومنشئها
ولانها تقع بين وحاحتين فهذا يجعل موقعها
مهما جدا الى الان كل شيء كان مثيرا جدا
وكذلك رؤيه سيف الملك كان امرا رائع
يحكي متحف الدرعيه عن احلى الظروف وحتى
افضل لها التي مرت بها الدرعيه حصار
الدرعيه في الدوله السعوديه الاولى كان من
ابرز المحطات التي تحدث عنها بالاضافه الى
عرضه لبعض المقتنيات للمره الاولى ومنها
المدافع التي استخدمتها الدوله العثمانيه
همم التي هاجمت وحاصره الدرعيه في محاوله
اسقاطها في ذلك الوقت
التجربه مثيره جدا لانني احب مشاهده
الاماكن الثقافيه مثل هذا لقد تعرفت على
الازياء وعلى التاريخ وكيف انشئت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكيف تطورت مع مرور
الزمن انها تجربه مسليه جدا ومثيره
بالنسبه لي في هذا الموقع هو اخر موقع في
متحف الدرعيه حيث يتم عرض ابرز القطع
واهمه التي توقف عندها الناس
تحدث عن السيف الاجرب ونسخه للطب نسخه طبق
الاصل من السيف الاجرب وهو سيف الامام
تركي بن عبد الله مؤسس الدوله السعوديه
الثانيه وكان احد ابرز واهم سيوف على
مستوى المنطقه وكتبت به القصائد
في تلك المنطقه او المرحله التاريخيه لهذا
السيد بالاضافه الى عدد من مقتنيات الاخرى
يختم بها زائر رحلته في متحف الدرعيه الذي
هو واحد من سته متاحه في اخرى في
دي الطريف التاريخي تغوص بك بتاريخ
الدرعيه حتى من ناحيه الخيول العربيه
الاصيله والتجاره والنزول وغيرها من
الرحله المتكامله لزائر والسائح في
الدرعيه عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الدرعيه
يتخذ الابل في السعوديه الحذاء وسيله
للتواصل مع ابلهم وهو الموروث السعودي
الذي تم ادراجه على لائحه يونسكو للتراث
الثقافيه
[موسيقى]
انا بخير
كان العرب القدماء يعظمون شهر رجب واسم
رجب ماخوذ من رجوب اي التعظيم التفاصيل في
تقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهر السابع من شهور السنه العربيه بين
قوسين الهجريه يسمى برجب ورجب ماخوذ من
الرجوب اي التعظيم فقد كانت العرب تعظم
هذا الشهر واكثر القبائل تقديسا لهذا
الشهر هم قبيلته مضر ولهذا يسمى برج ابو
مضر وهو احد الاشهر الحرم الاربعه محرم
ورجب واذا القعده وذا الحجه وهي الاشهر
التي يحرم فيها العرب القتال الا دفاعا عن
النفس وعن ارض الوطن بلاد الالفناها على
كل حاله وقد يؤله شيء الذي ليس بالحسن
ونستعذب الارض الذي لا هوى بها ولا ماؤها
عذب ولكنها
وطن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واشهر يوما انجيل الطيبين واحد سبعه فهو
موعد ميلاد معظم السعوديين منذ عقود فهم
يشتركون باليوم والشهر ويختلفون بالسنه
ورجب لهذه السنه نصها الاول شباط مقطع
ارباب ونصفها ثاني العقارب
ترى الخير
جاب
[موسيقى]
الرابع
لاوكرانيا
وسائل الاعلام الكويتيه تقول ان الحكومه
تنويه تقدمه غدا في استقالتها للقياده
السياسيه
الجمارك السعوديه تطلق مبادره لانهاء فتح
البضائع خلال ساعتين في كافه المنافذ
شكرا لكرم يا طيب المتابعه نهائيه